هل نقدر نقول دلوقتي في زي تناغم كبير بين
الفنانين والفنانات في الوطن العربي من
ناحيه ثاني ممكن تلاقيه فنان بيغني بلهجه
بلد عربي اخر وهكذا
هي اللغه الوحيده اللي العالم كله
بيتكلمها دي حقيقه يعني مش هنقول فيها
رايي لان الموسيقى هي انت بتسمعي اغاني مش
فاهمه منها ولا كلمه بس بتخليك مبسوطه
وبتسمعيها صحيح ولا مش صحيح والله ما في
حدود وطننا العربي المفروض ما يبقاش في
حدود ما يبقاش فيه
متاثر
لبناني يغني مصري مصري يغني خليجي خليجي
يغني هو هو هو ده حلاوتنا ده هو ده عظمتنا
عظمه العرب واحد
[موسيقى]
شايفه ازاي الظاهره الجديده
المهرجانات والرعب
والشباب اللي بيقبل عليها
شايفها يعني شايف الظهيره دي ازاي
ما فيش احد واصي على حد ما فيش حاجه اسمها
كده
عظمه الفن عظمه الموسيقى في تنوحها ان
فيها شعبي وفيها مهرجانات وفيها رعب وفيها
دي دي عظمه التنوع ظاهره
فضلت تكبر تكبر تكبر تكبر
الاولاد بتوع المهرجانات
شوفوا النتائج حصل
[موسيقى]
رايك ايه في المطربين الراب المصريين
وطالما بيحضر لهم بالمئات
الالافين جدا انا انا متابع
الاولاد الاولاد
[موسيقى]
مش حاجه عليه الناس الطفره الفنيه الكبيره
اللي شهادتها المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
السنوات الاخيره هيك شايفها ازاي وما
تاثيرها على الوطن العربي
مبهر وفخر لكل عربي اا هو ال- ال- ال-
الحلاوه في الموضوع دوت ان لما جاءت
اللحظه الانطلاق السعوديه ثقافيه وهمم
يعني
ثقافيه فنان الحقيقه همم ان هم كانوا
مستعدين يعني همم كانوا مستعدين بيجيء لي
متعلم احلى تعليم جيل مثقف ثقافه عظيمه
يعني انا بابص للي بيحصل في السعوديه وانا
راسي مرفوعه
همم في السعوديه الحفله بتاعه التريو اللي
هم عملوها السنه اللي فاتت السنه دي هتبقى
بشكل جديد خالص همم وبعدين عندي حفله رابح
صقر ليله رابح صقر يوم سته يناير باذن
الله وبعدين احتمال كبير نعمل ليله انغام
ان شاء الله في الرياض باذن الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كانوا خطر جدا عليها يعني وعلى همم
تبقى بكامل صحتها يعني همم بس فضل ربنا
بركه جمهورها واهلها واللي بيحبوها
يعني الخطر راح وبقت دلوقتي احسن كثير